thinking no more talk of BC however
noise race help you don't know now you
know your life is different now look at
this some thank you with mamrie Hart I
guess we're doing something completely
out of our comfort zone for drinking
vodka oh my god I thought that were
taking time away from the vodka were
already drinking oh yes
I don't know Sunday Cheers
so we've done this on my channel before
with you guys where you taste tested
high-end and low-end vodka yeah and now
it's the holiday season so we're making
a series of holiday videos together and
I thought it we'd fun since there's so
many flavored vodkas out there to have
you guys kind of blindly taste some
flavored holiday-ish related vodkas and
see if you can guess the flavor I was
like are you guys okay like sipping
vodka today and both of you were like
yeah I'm not excited about flavored
vodka though I'm not gonna lie really
sometimes it's really good it's like
dangerously I don't know I've never
asked flavored liquor I think it's like
that okay well today we may change your
mind
I doubt it so I found six different
flavored vodkas it's the closest I could
get to holiday-ish related flavors so
we'll see what happens
I haven't really thought this through I
don't know what you guys win by being
wait let's wait buzz we get to spend
time together that's fun for me the
holidays are all about yeah
[Music]
this is just sipping I have to point out
that on the chocolate beans tongue fun
here we go cheers today I think I know I
think I know let's hear your guesses
butterscotch cinnamon roll you're both
wrong buttered popcorn caramel no butter
jelly bean butter bright now
carrots one brown sugar in the bank
together you've made drinks with
pinnacle cupcake vodka oh yes this is
gonna go the point it just takes your 20
minutes to get to it Oh back Brown to
imagine if you were a Russian person
guys like we do you want to try flavored
vodka and they were like what the
flavors do okay Cheers
round two Cheers Oh trust me these are
all flavors I could take a setting thing
I need a palate cleanser other both
you're about to get me try again
I can't that one honestly does not taste
again I thought it was gonna be but this
also like the last one is not a very
good holiday it's the closest I could
kind of get I can't taste anything I
taste rubbing alcohol air yep is it also
a Starbucks drink it's a flavor of a
Starbucks drink oh no I'm not gonna lie
I feel drunk right now
[Music]
vanilla yeah I know I should be way more
pleasant than it is I'm gonna rinse
these out this time though sure
rich crapper yeah yeah there you go man
I got a snack for you oh I love a red
cracker here's the thing about risk
factor brunch
it's just Ritz crackers and Boggs Cheers
hi guys just babysitting hurry up Cheers
cinnamon this one's not bad caramel and
tastes like caramel kissed caramel I
don't know what that means it means
someone in the factory makes outlets
every back I'm looking for some savory
flavors what do you want a flamin hot
cheetos vodka so these last three I have
never tasted before in my life okay you
want us to close our eyes I'm looking
for like a spring your eyes aren't
closed Oh
buh-bam okay number four peppermint
[Applause]
could you take a shot then you make out
with somebody really you don't need gum
before you make out with someone
seriously that is a life cycle if you
hear at the bar and you've done like
drinking red wine all night but you know
you're about the smooth should take a
shot of rum oh man oh yeah we guys won
every record label is overconfident
I can't my own sinuses are bad I don't I
smell it
George Michael Hobbs backing this up so
much oh my god a buttery peppermint Wow
what if I just had peppermint vodka
that's truly okay here's number five
Oh nutmeg I mean eggnog yeah it's eggnog
hundred percent what do you think it was
I've never had egg nog read I wonder
what I had never had
the way she said it maybe she likes her
mouth is going I'm never speaking and my
friend was like this is actually really
good it was lovely
so on to our last round I've never had
this Cheers
oh is it bacon is it jerky say it take
it you know you might ready so I'm not
gonna do it it's vegan I looked it up
smells like they oh it's bacon it's
bacon bacon flavored vegan bacon this
honestly they say it's best for your
bloody marys your bloody Caesar subside
reck cetera tastes very bad this is
exactly what I think liquid smoke okay
fire tastes like to me it tastes like a
beggin strips like that dog like you
don't treat way decided these taste like
this tastes like beggin strips well I
don't think this is meant to ever be
drank the way morganite martini or
sniffed if you make martinis with this
little Ernie with a little pickle gee
I'm sorry guys if it smells better basic
come on it smells bad it smells like
beans as treats
I'm not sniffing my backup before I
drink it I sniff everything I said my
deodorant before I put it on anyway this
has been a box yeah
I expected you to do well and you really
you delivered I'm really proud of you oh
my god I'm gonna call you my friends and
I'm glad that we get to spend this
holiday time together guys don't do this
now it's another video okay
oh not on me watching make sure to
subscribe leave comments down below
whenever you want now and don't forget
to check out the videos every mainland
may where in Hannah's channels they're
very fun we're making gingerbread houses
over here and we're sniffing out some
candles over here so go check it out
also drink responsibly especially over
the holiday season have fun enjoy your
holiday at the center except enemies
unlock this outro of 2008 takes good
girls but talk for an hour about rich
cracker it's a good feeling the space
here's the thing about risk factor on
the box
they're always preaching this [ __ ]
about stuff you can put on top of her
it's cracker just like I would never
want to eat something off this because
it would be bad you know I wouldn't
because you know you always think a
little hors d'oeuvres on the back of us
cracker boxes and they're gonna be
sitting out for more than like 30
seconds well you got to do like a
Triscuit or something with some real
good hey no one wants a soggy bottom I
like traitors break off they say that a
lot yeah they're sweet they do have a
little sweetness to it I would never
want to eat anything on top of it you
know what I did is I made a squash
casserole and I crumble these with a
bunch of what the fresh thyme the only
time with this [ __ ] but what is wrong
with it why don't they get their [ __ ]
together
nobody wants something on a Ritz well
you want it crush on top of something
else or just playing guys are still okay
anyway these crackers remember when the
slab
oh you're like a mini-me lemony they're
gonna get stale I know but now they pack
them in like quadrants yeah then you're
like well I'll give you I guess I have
to finish these this is why I hate this
and I'm friends with yeah this is the
perfect size to throw in a backpack
there let me now say I granted
manifesting this brand you know kids
yeah it's all I got
intro mold sleeve that's enough to share
control asleep look like